djay puts us in the building donnatella
t-mobile three words for you
treat yo so treat yourself mm once a
year Donna and I spend a day treating
ourselves what do we treat ourselves to
clothes
treat yourself fragrances treat yourself
massages freaky stuff mimosa
treat yourself fine leather goods treat
yourself it's the best day of the year
the best day of year I got a question
mm-hmm what do you think about inviting
Ben to come along with us today
whoa this is our thing he really seems
like he could use a day off
he's like a skinny little rubber band
that's about to snap in half
exactly he doesn't know how to relax
Donna you and I are relaxation
professionals there's no way Ben can
slow down enough to keep up with us my
nubian princess this is our holy day
it's a one day a year I allow myself to
be selfish cupcake those are all for me
Jerry I don't know what to do I could
take the offer and break even but I've
come so far Ron can you put some more
tiny marshmallows in my hot chocky thank
you if there was something I could do
for you I would maybe you should try
taking a walk out of my office what
Watson blue what is blue sh bloosh is a
weekly lifestyle email written by
Annabel Porter she used to be the face
of the Eagleton phonebook then she moved
to Hollywood to pursue her dream of
becoming friends with a bunch of
celebrities then she moved back to
become a lifestyle guru she's legit she
spent four months living in Kate
Bosworth pool house Ron Swanson design
chair is the must-have item of the
season along with red quinoa wind
therapy and buying an island
Annabelle says that buying an island is
the only real way to know that you goji
berry farm is pesticide free I've been
trying to get rent-a-swag in bloosh for
months and now you got in I can get into
congratulations for all we did it
someone's getting a new leather jacket I
don't want a leather jacket it's for me
this is a great day
ron's in bloosh so treat yourself day is
just a day where you go to the spa and
then the mall I knew you wouldn't get it
well I'm a relaxation novice need some
guidance
listen to me bento box the point of this
is to pamper yourself
just relax man I can't something about
the sound of harps that makes me nervous
oh my god I don't know hey relaxation
lesson number one acupuncture is great
for your back and your rear needles in
your face pleasure in yo base I really
want this dress and I like this crystal
beetle but it's expensive and there's no
use for it
Donna mEagle treat yourself velvet
slippies
cashmere socks velvet pants cashmere
turtle I'm a cashmere velvet candy cane
treat yo'self
this is insane man did you buy anything
for yourself today yeah I got this pack
of socks plain white socks that's not a
treat Donna get me away from him maybe
this is our version of treat yourself
day and he needs to do this version what
are you talking about why if you've got
big money on one thing not soft money
what would it be oh my god oh my god oh
my god this is a whole new level of nerd
you're right this is ridiculous
what do I do wait no no no no no I mean
that in a good way Ben listen to me
you're part of the treat yourself team
now okay if that costume somehow makes
you happy
you're gonna buy it and you're gonna
wear it out of the store okay you're
gonna treat yourself yeah you know what
I'm gonna do that I'm gonna I'm gonna
treat myself thanks you guys
thank you
I really needed this I get it to myself
uh uh
Batman's crying your favorite kind of
cake can't be birthday cake that's like
saying your favorite con cereals
breakfast sir mmm I love breakfast
cereal look some kind of bird let's kill
it you're talking to me [ __ ] what are
you aiming at nothing all right be
honest tom how did you and I get matched
up
I made 26 profiles each designed to
attract a different type of girl Tom a
Haverford sporty and sexy
Tom B have furred smooth and soulful
which letters you get and Tom n
Haverford the in Stanford nerd I never
even check that one because no one ever
responds to it okay well whatever Tom n
Haverford collects Globes great that's
enough his favorite movie is books Donna
every time I want you to shut up from
now on
I like the vanilla one with the lemon
cream that was a joke cake I got from
the grocery store to weed out low
quality pallets maybe it's cuz he's my
fiancee and I love him
but I kind of like the grocery store
wantin there's actually one more cake
you haven't tried yet Donna has chosen
me to be the butler of honor at her
wedding now granted Butler of honor is a
term I made up but it's not a job I take
lightly that's why I'm about to give her
a surprise bigger than when LeBron went
back to Miami Oh DJ bluntz
what is happening right now I think you
know what's at
but but for real though treat yourself
oh it's be real and it's the biggest one
yet I still don't know what's happening
what's happening Jesus
not an answer it's my question oh my god
read the cake still unclear tell you
what what's happening treat yo self is
the best damn here
can we talk about that disastrous
interaction you just have it Lucy nope
all we're talking about is treatment
yourself today's about one thing things
things done our favorite well where is
months thickness this is not the way to
the moment that's cuz we're not going to
the mall we're finally gonna do
something we've always talked about no
treat yo'self in Beverly Hills and
gentlemen off to our right you can see
the house belongs to Bruce Willis and
Christina Aguilera and to our left is uh
sure's Los Angeles resident
[Music]
so for the basic elbow vajazzling it's
140 custom art starts at 250
I would like three big-ass diamonds
surrounded by their own set of tiny ass
diamonds that would fall into our
supreme collection 600 Thomas what do
you suggest uh treat yourself
Church the gentleman is right I'm gonna
behave and treat myself lazy for
fingernails I came up with that you want
it it's 275 yeah laser my nails off
please this is the hottest restaurant in
LA all the sushi is made from fish
previously owned by celebrities okay
this is Charlie's their owns yellowtail
here we have Paul Reiser's salmon and
Peter Bogdanovich's saltwater it you
enjoy mm-hmm
man you got it bad I know you're
checking your phone every five minutes
to see if Lucy will come with you to my
wedding I'm sorry
hey I understand which is why I got you
something hey you're not supposed to get
me anything this is your special day I
didn't buy you anything what I have for
you is a piece of advice oh damn
Oh secretly hoping you got me the shoes
Jane Smith wears and hitch to son of a
hitch my advice to you is if you want to
be with Lucy you have to be upfront with
her about it be a man and ask her out
she works for me she uprooted her whole
life to move to Pawnee for this job I
don't want to make it weird and what if
she says no what if I'm the only one the
coffee Ling's you won't know until you
ask
basically Tommy when it comes to matters
of the heart I say treat yourself thanks
Donna it's a great gift
I almost forgot I did get you Tim -
spits - oh snap that's an even better
gift that's not all
look behind you but don't be obvious
could I get uh the me soft-shell crab
josh groban he's eating his own so she
doesn't want baller thing I've ever seen
you